here's black lesbian press secretary
Karin Jean-Pierre refusing to say if the
government's ever going to give up their
National Emergency Powers what is the
criteria the country
for it not to be an
emergency or is that even a goal so
here's the thing we cannot forget that
covet is still a problem we just had Dr
Jacques here talking to all of you he
wanted to be here and we wanted him to
be to all of you because you guys
communicate with the American people and
we want we want that the American people
to know that there is a new vaccine out
there and they need to get that shot in
the arm no you don't need to get it and
you don't have to listen to these people
they are not your parents they are not
your doctor they are not your conscience
and they are not your God I know they'd
like to be all of those things but they
are none of those things you know how to
take care of yourself and that must be
the Republican message going forward and
it is and you can see it Oz said it last
night
um zeldin said it last night what has
Blake Masters been saying what has
Carrie Lake been saying what has JD
Vance been saying the the discrepancy
and the Divide between the parties has
never been more clear do you want a
bunch of of Mind muddled bureaucrats to
force you to do things with your body
and inject your children with things and
then they'll chop their genitals off as
a bonus or do you want to be left alone
with a little more money in your pocket
with a little more chance that it's on
you how you will live your life it's up
to you it's up to you man but I am
telling you the machine is going to go
into overdrive for the next 12 days or
so and they're going to try to freak
everybody out not only with covid but
fascism is coming and the Nazis are back
at everything else